qu'on a pu mesurer à quel point
le maire de Saint-Brevin a été livré
quelque part à lui-même il a clairement
indiqué qu'elles avaient été les étapes
successives des déconvenus qu'il avait
été amené à subir pour porter un projet
qui relève de l'État et malheureusement
on voit à quel point les élus les ailes
sont face à eux-mêmes sans avoir
suffisamment dans certains cas pas dans
tous mais l'accompagnement de l'État
l'accompagnement également de la justice
et je crois que
l'audition de ce matin elle a révélé à
quel point il était aujourd'hui
nécessaire de pouvoir mieux accompagner
les élus dans leur protection les
accompagner parfois même sur le plan
psychologique et puis je crois que la
réponse elle doit commencer très
rapidement avec les services de l'État
et l'État doit se manifester pour
accompagner ces élus qui se trouvent
dans une forme de détresse et très
souvent trop seul
je crois que les élus se sont avant tout
des citoyens qui ont pris
cette responsabilité qui s'engage au
service du bien commun au service de
l'intérêt général et qui sont en même
temps dépositaires de l'autorité
publique donc il n'échappe pas la
violence latente et qui s'exprime tous
les jours dans notre dans notre société
et je crois qu'il convient justement de
prendre à bras le corps ce sujet
aujourd'hui si on veut résumer
synthétiser l'élu a trop le sentiment
d'être seul et la conséquence elle est
très directe c'est un affaiblissement à
terme de la vie démocratique locale et
pour nous la nécessité finalement de re
questionner ce sujet et de formuler des
propositions très concrètes qui
permettront de revisiter les conditions
d'exercice des mandaloko
en d'autres termes comment on redonne à
la fois de la confiance comment on
redonne des moyens précontrés aux maires
de pouvoir exercer leur mandat local
[Musique]